währenddessen hat die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin den nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt nämlich 23 abgerufen
und zwar zu Barrierefreiheit und
inklusive im Sozialraum am Puls sehen
Sie Wilfried Oellers von der
Unionsfraktion die Strecke zwischen
Berlin und Hannover bewältigen müssen
ein Liedchen zu singen
viel Zeit und Geduld mitbringen für
viele Menschen mit Behinderungen ist
dies nicht nur ein temporäres Problem
sondern gehört zum Alltag nicht nur in
Bahnverkehr wenn der gewünschte
Zielbahnhof keinen Fahrstuhl hat das
Servicepersonal nur bis zum frühen Abend
im Einsatz ist oder der Rollstuhlplatz
im ICE schon ausgebucht ist
genauso wenn die Produkte Information im
einkaufsregal für sehbehinderte Menschen
nicht lesbar ist oder die Suche nach der
Facharztpraxis mit höhenverstellbaren
Untersuchungsgeräten oder Informationen
in leichter Sprache
zeitraubenden Unterfangen wird manchmal
können Zeit und Geduld auch zur
Lebensgefahr werden so wie 2021 in
Sinzig als Menschen mit kognitiven
Beeinträchtigungen nicht rechtzeitig
gewarnt wurden und in den Fluten
ertranken diese wenigen Beispiele zeigen
der Weg hin zu einer barrierefreien
Gesellschaft an den an der Menschen mit
und ohne Behinderung ist allen
Lebensbereichen teilhaben können von der
aber auch Eltern mit Kinderwagen oder
ältere Menschen profitieren ist kein
leichter
auch wenn wir in den letzten Jahren viel
geschafft haben und auch erdacht haben
ich denke hier an dieser Erweiterung des
Behindertengleichstellungsgesetzes das
barrierefreiheitsstärkungsgesetz viele
weitere gesetzlichen Maßnahmen und die
Initiative Sozialraum inklusiv des
Bundesministeriums für Arbeit und
Soziales und der bundesfachstelle
Barrierefreiheit
letztere Initiative aber vor allem aber
vor allem viele Begegnungen mit Menschen
mit Behinderung und anderen Akteuren
haben uns als Unionsfraktion gute
Anregungen geliefert für einen
ausführliches zehn Punkte Papier zum
inklusiven Sozialraum dessen Lektüre ich
sehr empfehle und den Antrag den wir
Ihnen heute vorlegen es ist das erste
Mal dass wir in dieser Legislaturperiode
hier im Plenum über Barrierefreiheit
diskutieren
was durchaus erstaunt wenn man in den
Koalitionsvertrag der Ampel schaut doch
von den dort genannten ambitionierten
Vorhaben hat bislang keins den Bundestag
erreicht immerhin aus dem ursprünglich
angekündigten Bundesprogramm
Barrierefreiheit wird zwar erstmal
nichts aber gerade noch rechtzeitig vor
dem morgigen internationalen Tag der
Menschen mit Behinderungen hat die
Bundesregierung am Mittwoch eine
Bundesinitiative Barrierefreiheit
verabschiedet löblich und gut was drin
angekündigt wird aber schon das Papier
des Koalitionsvertrags war bisher recht
geduldig
eins zumindest eint die Bundesinitiative
und unseren Antrag
barrierefreiheit ist ein
Querschnittsthema
Mobilität Bauen und Wohnen Gesundheit
Digitalisierung
Katastrophenschutz aber auch
Produktentwicklung und Produkten
politische Partizipation das sind längst
nicht alle aber doch einige wichtige
Lebensbereiche die wir uns
herausgegriffen haben
hier wollen wir fördern und fordern mehr
Förderung eine Aufstockung des
kfw-programms altersgerecht umbauen
weitere KfW-Programme unter anderem für
den Gesundheitsbereich und barrierefreie
Produktentwicklung verbunden mit einer
Übergangsfrist von fünf Jahren und einer
Überforderungsklausel fordern wir die
rechtliche Verankerung von angemessenen
Vorkehrungen auch im Privatbereich es
muss endlich eine Bestandsaufnahme und
danach die umfassende barrierefreie
Umgestaltung aller öffentlich
zugänglichen Bundesbauten geben übrigens
gerade die Gebäude des Deutschen
Bundestages dürfen gerne mit gutem
Beispiel vorangehen
mehr
mehr rechtliche Verbindlichkeit brauchen
wir für die Barrierefreiheit im ÖPNV wir
machen konkrete Vorschläge für mehr
Tempo bei der Barrierefreiheit im
Bahnverkehr im taxiwesen und bei der
barrierefreien lade Infrastruktur
mehr bundesweite Einheitlichkeit
brauchen wir auch in Regelungen zur
Barrierefreiheit im Bauordnungsrecht wir
fordern auch eine Stärkung der
Barrierefreiheit in der aus- und
Weiterbildung von Architekten und
Ingenieuren bis hin zu einem eigenen
Studiengang und wir brauchen ein Träger
und
ebenenübergreifendes Beratungs-
weitere Beispiele finden sich in unserem
Antrag zu diesen und weiteren Bereichen
machen wir Ihnen heute Vorschläge und
bringen Gedanken ein in die Diskussion
gut ist wir beginnen bei allem nicht bei
Null viele gute Beispiele machen Mut ob
inklusives wohnen und
Unterstützungsangebote der Stiftung
Hamburg Alsterdorf ein gebärdensprach
Avatar der den Beipackzettel von
Medikamenten erläutert oder die
Regionalbahnstrecke in meinem Wahlkreis
an der mittlerweile alle Bahnhöfe
barrierefrei umgebaut sind lassen Sie
uns gemeinsam an einer Barrieren und ein
Gesellschaft in allen Lebensbereichen
arbeiten denn weitere Verzögerungen im
Betriebsablauf sollten wir uns nicht
leisten und herzliche Grüße an Gerald
Huber danke schön
soweit zum Auftakt dieser Debatte der
unionsantrag mehr Tempo für
Barrierefreiheit und einen inklusiven
Sozialraum das war Wilfried Oellers für
die Unionsfraktion der auch beauftragt
ist für die Teilhabe von Menschen mit
Behinderungen
seiner Unionsfraktion jetzt für die
SPD-Fraktion und habe es mir mit Ali er
ist der Beauftragte für die Belange von
Menschen mit Behinderung für die
SPD-Fraktion Tempo für Barrierefreiheit
und ein inklusiven Sozialraum wenn man
dann irgendwann mal so den Antrag
durchliest bevor die ganzen Aufzählungen
kommen ließ man dann naja die Ampel sei
ja schon seit einem Jahr dran und hätte
noch nicht geliefert liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir waren ja jetzt schon
sehr sehr lange zusammen in einer
Koalition gewesen wir hätten 12 Jahre 16
Jahre gemeinsam liefern können und das
ist ja an ihnen geblockt worden ich
glaube die einzige die einzige Blockade
in diesem Land sind die Uni ist die
Unionsfraktion meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren
ja aber an uns ist es ja nicht
gescheitert also an der Sozialdemokratie
sind die ganzen Vorhaben nicht
gescheitert unsere jetzigen
Koalitionspartner FDP und die Grünen
haben wir zu Recht all das gefordert was
wir jetzt im Koalitionsvertrag verankert
haben das ist möglich weil wir jetzt
eine progressive Regierung haben
eine Zwischenfrage zulassen aus der CD
gerne
auf den Kollegen kann man ja nicht sauer
sein
ich weiß nicht
ich könnte sauer sein wenn er zu lange
spricht
ich werde mich kurz fassen sehr geehrter
Kollege Mehmet Ali vielen Dank dass Sie
die Zwischenfrage zulassen
da sie jetzt ja auf die
Regierungszeiten der letzten
Wahlperioden zu sprechen kommen
und da sie jetzt ja auch neu im
Bundestag sind will ich fragen ob sie
doch zur Kenntnis nehmen dass wir gerade
in der letzten Legislaturperiode und ich
habe es eben eine Rede erwähnt schon
mehrere große Gesetzgebungsverfahren auf
dem Weg gebracht haben bei
Barrierefreiheit stärkungsgesetz war ein
Beispiel und
Behindertengleichstellungsgesetz das
andere und der Hinweis sei mal erlaubt
in der letzten Legislaturperiode war der
das erste Gesetz dass wir im Ausschuss
für Arbeit und Soziales hier im
Deutschen Bundestag beschlossen haben
ein Gesetz was gerade Menschen mit
Behinderung betroffen und zwar ging es
um die Barrierefreiheit von öffentlichen
Stellen und Behörden das haben wir
damals beschlossen das erste Gesetz und
sind zwei große gefolgt deswegen bitte
ich Sie das zur Kenntnis zu nehmen
vielen vielen Dank das ist mir natürlich
bewusst mir ist auch bewusst dass wir es
mit ihnen geschafft haben 2016 das
großartige bundesteilhabegesetz
einzuführen dass er wirklich zu einem
riesengroßen Schritt zu einer inklusiven
Welt gebracht hat aber letztendlich
kommen wir nur ein riesengroßen Schritt
weiter wenn wir auch dafür die
finanziellen Mitteln zur Verfügung
stellen und das war einfach mit ihnen
nicht möglich gewesen das wird aber in
dieser Koalition möglich sein indem wir
vieles was wir auch im Bereich des
inklusiv Wohnungsbaus vor uns haben auch
in der Mobilität vor uns haben auch
umsetzen werden ohne Geld geht da gar
nichts und das haben sie auch blockiert
da war ja nichts möglich gewesen und das
werden wir jetzt machen und im übrigen
wir haben jetzt die ersten Eckpunkte die
ersten Eckpunkte zur Verfügung gestellt
für die Bundesinitiative
Barrierefreiheit das ist ja nur der
Anfang dafür dass wir ein riesengroßes
Bundesprogramm haben werden nämlich für
eine vollumfängliche und ganzheitliches
barrierefreies Deutschland und das war
leider vorher nicht möglich mit Ihnen
das muss man auch ganz klar sagen
aber wenn ich weitermachen darf meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren sie haben
auch geschrieben dass wir mehr Tempo im
Wohnungsbau brauchen wenn ich mich so an
2009 erinnere ich persönlich war da zwar
17 18 Jahre alt gewesen
2009 wurde die
unbehindertenrechtskonvention
ratifiziert
ich kann mich erinnern dass es ein
Bundesland gab unter CDU-Führung
Baden-Württemberg beispielsweise dass in
demselben Jahr der
UN-Behindertenrechtskonvention die
landesheimbauverordnung verabschiedet
hat den Bau von 24er Wohnheimen während
die
UN-Behindertenrechtskonvention gefordert
hat dass mehr selbstbestimmtes Wohnen
Das mehr personenzentriertes wohnen
gefördert werden soll kam
Baden-Württemberg auf nichts anderes als
ein 24er Wohnheim für Menschen mit
Behinderung zu fördern und Mittel dafür
zur Verfügung zu stellen und zusätzlich
noch Mitte der Ausgleichsabgabe die für
den inklusiven Arbeitsmarkt zu zur
Verfügung gestellt werden sollen für
diesen Wohnbau nämlich für diese 24er
Wohnheime zu verwenden ich habe noch
heute eine Leistungsbescheid von 2018 da
aus dem KVJS dass das ausdrücklich so
ausstellt das Mittel der
Ausgleichsabgabe für 24er Wohnheime
verwendet werden und das werden wir
verbieten nämlich mit dem Antrag was
Anfang nächsten Jahres beraten wird auch
hier mit dem Antrag zur inklusiven
Arbeitswelt indem wir verbieten werden
das Mittel der Ausgleichsabgabe für
solche 24er Wohnheime genutzt werden
können meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
ergänzend noch
Tempo bei der barrierefreien Mobilität
12 Jahre Union geführtes
Verkehrsministerium Ramsauer Dobrind
scheuer im Antrag fordern sie eine
vollumfängliche barrierefreie Mobilität
ich frage mich aber auch hier naja das
hätten wir ja auch gemeinsam in den
letzten Jahren machen können warum kommt
das jetzt alles und Herr Oehler sie
wissen nicht ich mag sie als Person sie
sind ein kompetenter Kollege aber das
hätten wir wirklich doch gemeinsam auch
in der groko in den letzten Jahren
machen können warum haben wir das nicht
gemacht das ist für mich auch eine
riesengroße Frage deshalb freue ich mich
dass wir das jetzt in der Ampel umsetzen
werden können
zum Schluss sie haben
sie haben im 20 Punkt ihres Antrages den
Paragrafen 78 Absatz 5 SGB 9 erwähnt da
geht es um Ehrenamt und um die
Assistenzleistungen
das ist ein Problem dass ich tatsächlich
auch sehe deshalb haben wir auch die
Evaluation des bundesteilhabegesetzes in
Koalitionsvertrag verankert aber ich
sage Ihnen eins wenn wir schaffen dass
das bundesteilhabegesetz in den Ländern
so ausgeführt wird wie wir das gemeinsam
beschlossen haben dann wird sich dieses
Problem auch von selbst beheben wir
müssen aber auch schaffen dass jeder
Mensch mit Behinderung zu seinem Recht
kommt so wie wir das im sgb-9 verankert
haben dann glaube ich auch dass wir
wirklich zu einer inklusiven
Gemeinschaft kommen können meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren ich freue mich
auf die gemeinsame Zusammenarbeit
trotzdem und freue mich dann wenn Sie
zukünftig unseren Anträgen zustimmen
vielen Dank
ein wichtiges Thema das sehr viel mehr
gehört verdient und die Barrierefreiheit
für Menschen mit Handicap in Deutschland
mittlerweile hat amput übernommen die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Petra Pao die
hier noch mal auf das bevorstehende Ende
der namentlichen Abstimmung zum
Jahressteuergesetz hinweist gleich
fahren wir also in der Debatte fort über
die Barrierefreiheit jeder der mal in
Deutschland mobil gewesen ist egal ob im
nah oder im Fernverkehr wird das häufig
festgestellt haben zum Beispiel die
schöne Erfahrung des umsteigen auf einem
Bahnhof von einem Gleis zum anderen und
das nicht vorhanden sein oder zum
Beispiel das nicht funktionieren eines
Aufzuges das ist schon unter normalen
Umständen nicht wirklich sinnvoll aber
mit Handicap fast nicht zu machen
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
die Unionsfraktion beklagt völlig zu
Recht dass die selbst ernannte
fortschrittskoalition zu wenig für
Menschen mit Behinderung macht und legt
mit diesem Antrag ein umfassendes
Maßnahmepaket vor die
Bewusstseinsbildung für das Thema der
Barrierefreiheit insbesondere in der
Architekten und Ingenieursausbildung
soll gestärkt werden sogar barrierefreie
taxi-angebote ein großes Problem im
ländlichen Raum wird thematisiert und
auch ein bundesweites Förderprogramm zum
Aufbau barrierefreier digitaler
Infrastruktur und digitaler Kompetenzen
in außer betrieblichen
Ausbildungsstätten aber auch in den
Werkstätten für behinderte Menschen wird
angestrebt ihr Antrag Inhalte
tatsächlich sehr gute Ansätze das muss
man ihnen lassen aber so ein Antrag ist
natürlich der blanke Hohn wenn er
ausgerechnet von der CDU CSU kommt ich
weiß sie wollen es nicht mehr hören aber
man darf einfach nicht vergessen dass
sie es waren dieses Land nicht nur die
letzten 16 Jahre sondern ein Großteil
seit Bestehen der Bundesrepublik regiert
geprägt und moralisch wie materiell
verwahrlost haben
wer der Kollegen von der Union auch der
Zustand des Sozialwesens fällt zu einem
nicht geringen Anteil in ihre
Verantwortung warum fordern Sie diese
Verbesserung also erst dann wenn sie mit
der Umsetzung nichts mehr zu tun haben
müssen in ihren Reihen sitzen ja
offenbar bewusste Sozialpolitiker aber
warum konnten sich diese nicht in den
letzten Jahrzehnten mal darum kümmern
dass diese Dinge umgesetzt werden warum
spielen sie sich gerade jetzt als
soziale Stimme der Menschen mit
Behinderung auf entweder bestand nie der
Wille sich wirklich um die Belange von
Menschen mit Behinderung zu kümmern oder
es ist jetzt ganz plötzlich als
taktisches Kalkül für ihre
Opposition Darstellung interessant
geworden
sie versuchen offenbar sie versuchen
offenbar mit diesem Thema das soziale
Profil ihrer Partei aufzubessern was
wenn man mal ehrlich sind historisch
nicht gerade zur Eigenart der
Christdemokratie gehört hatte und so
kann man auch erkennen wo sie in ihrem
Antrag dann etwas auf die Bremse treten
denn der große blindfleck in ihrem
Antrag und der Debatte im allgemeinen
das sind die Schwerbehinderten zum
Jahresende 2021 lebten rund 7,8
Millionen schwerbehinderte Menschen in
Deutschland das sind fast zehn Prozent
der gesamten Bevölkerung meine Damen und
Herren für diese Menschen ist es zumeist
sehr schwer eine Festanstellung zu
erwerben und zu halten nicht zuletzt
weil sich die Unternehmen von der Quote
einfach frei kaufen können und das meine
Damen und Herren ist eine
Ungerechtigkeit die es endlich zu
beseitigen wird
[Applaus]
um das zu schaffen wäre eine komplett
neu konzipierte Ausgleichsabgabe für
Arbeitgeber von Nöten die sich auf dem
Niveau eines monatlichen
Durchschnittsgehalts eines
Vollzeitbeschäftigten im Betrieb bewegt
damit wäre endlich ein realistischer
Anreiz für Privatunternehmer und
öffentliche Arbeitgeber gegeben um das
gesetzliche fünf Prozent Ziel in
mittlerer Frist zu erreichen die hier
durch erzielten Mehreinnahmen erweitern
die finanziellen Mittel des
Integrationsamtes die eine intensivere
Begleitung von Arbeitnehmern mit
Behinderung ermöglichen warum fordern
sie nicht endlich die notwendigen
Schritte damit endlich mehr
schwerbehinderte in Lohn und Brot kommen
und sich die Unternehmen nicht länger
billig frei kaufen können das liebe
Kollegen von der Union würde doch mal
echte Inklusion bedeuten denn das ist
ein notwendiger Teil eines tatsächlich
sozialen Maßnahmenpaket und die
afd-fraktion wird sich darum kümmern
vielen Dank
dies hier der Redebeitrag von Hannes
Gnauck der afd-fraktion mit einem
konkreten Vorschlag den z.B das BMAS mit
einnehmen kann in die Bundesinitiative
Barrierefreiheit jetzt noch mal Petra
Pau das ist eine Stimme nicht abgegeben
hat
das ist nicht der Fall ich schließe die
Abstimmung und bitte die
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer mit
der Auszählung zu Beginn das Ergebnis
der Abstimmung wird Ihnen später bekannt
gegeben
wir fahren in der Debatte vor das Wort
hat die Kollegin Stefanie Effner für die
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und sie ist mit diesem Ausschuss für
Arbeit und Soziales an denen dieser
Antrag dann auch überwiesen wird zur
Debatte sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen ich danke der Union
ausdrücklich dass sie mit ihrem Antrag
uns heute Gelegenheit gibt über dieses
wichtige Thema Barrierefreiheit und
inklusiver Sozialraum zu reden 13 Jahre
nach in Kraft treten
Behindertenrechtskonvention in
Deutschland können Menschen mit
Behinderung zu Recht erwarten dass wir
dafür Sorge tragen dass sie in allen
Lebensbereichen gleichberechtigt
teilhaben können
barrierefreiheit ist dafür
Grundvoraussetzung und es war eine
rot-grüne Bundesregierung die 2002 das
Behindertengleichstellungsgesetz
verabschiedet hat und damit wirklich
einen Meilenstein geschaffen hat wir
haben den Bund zu Barrierefreiheit
verpflichtet und in der Folge sind auch
in vielen
landesbehindertengleichstellungsgesetzen
eben solche Verpflichtungen aufgenommen
eine Sache fehlt aber bis heute
die Verpflichtung zur Herstellung von
Barrierefreiheit im privaten Bereich und
auch im öffentlichen Bereich werden
Vorgaben oft nicht umgesetzt und genau
das gehen wir jetzt endlich gemeinsam an
am Mittwoch sind die Eckpunkte der
Bundesinitiative Barrierefreiheit
verabschiedet worden wir haben uns viel
vorgenommen wir wollen private endlich
zum Abbau von Barrieren verpflichten wir
wollen Schwerpunkte setzen in den
Bereichen Mobilität wohnen Gesundheit
und Digitalisierung
sie liebe Union fordern jetzt mehr Tempo
bei der Barrierefreiheit 16 Jahre lang
gab es in ihren Koalitionsverträgen vor
allen Dingen Waage Absichtserklärung sie
wollten zum Beispiel prüfen ob man
private verpflichten kann zur
angemessenen Vorkehrung zu aller erstem
Gesundheitssektor dass wir sagen und
schreiben nur 26 Prozent barrierefreie
Arztpraxen haben erzählt uns irgendwie
dass das nicht besonders erfolgreich war
und da noch viel Luft nach oben ist
jetzt wollen sie angemessene
Vorkehrungen einführen das begrüßen wir
ausdrücklich aber die Verpflichtung zum
Abbau von Barrieren versehen sie wieder
nur mit einem Prüfauftrag und sagen
schauen wir uns doch mal das Gesetz in
Österreich an ich sage Ihnen wir
arbeiten gerne mit Ihnen an der
Verpflichtung der angemessenen
Vorkehrungen zusammen aber haben Sie
keine Angst vor der Verpflichtung zum
Abbau von Barrieren der American Swiss
disability Act 1990 das österreichische
Behindertengleichstellungsgesetz 2016
oder England 2010 in all diesen Ländern
sind die Verpflichtungen Realität und
die Privatwirtschaft ist nicht
kollabiert im Gegenteil genau damit
sorgen wir dafür dass auch
Privatwirtschaft auch morgen noch Kunden
hat in Zeiten zunehmender Verlagerung in
den Online-
ich freue mich auf die Zusammenarbeit an
dieser Stelle
also bisher an dieser Debatte alle guten
Willens das war für die grüne Fraktion
Stefan die Effner die Mitglied im
Ausschuss ist der sich dann auch noch
mal intensiv mit diesem Antrag befassen
wird nächste Redner in dieser Debatte
der gleich von Petra Pau aufgerufen wird
Matthias birkwardt kommt aus der
Linksfraktion und es Sprecher nicht nur
für Rentenpolitik sondern auch für
alterssicherungspolitik
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren der vorliegende Antrag
der Unionsfraktion hat ein neues Level
an übermütiger Selbstbeweihräucherung
und politischer Vergesslichkeit erreicht
während sie liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der cdu/csu-fraktion ganze 16
Jahre ich kann es ihnen nicht ersparen
die Bundesregierung geführt haben sind
die durchaus vorhandenen Verbesserungen
in dieser Zeit doch sehr überschaubar
noch immer scheitern zahlreiche Menschen
mit Behinderungen beispielsweise an
Barrieren im Kino beim Einkaufen beim
Sport im Straßenverkehr in und mit
Behörden oder im Gesundheitswesen und
dass sie in ihrer Zeit als
Regierungsfraktion jedoch vollkommen
beratungsresistent waren zeigt sich an
ihrem Abstimmungsverhalten in der
Vergangenheit
2020 hatte die Linksfraktion 10 Anträge
für eine bessere Barrierefreiheit
eingebracht die haben sie alle abgelehnt
stattdessen mussten wir uns anhören
machen wir ist gemacht wird gemacht
haben wir längst erledigt Unsinn denn
ihre Bilanz ist verheerend
barrierefreier Wohnraum ist in
Deutschland
Goldstaub und in der Realität leider
völlig unbezahlbar unter Statistische
Bundesamt beziffert den Anteil an
barrierefreien Wohnungen auf nur
1,5%. die gleiche verheerende Bilanz auf
dem Arbeitsmarkt der Anteil der
langzeitarbeitssuchenden Menschen mit
Behinderungen stieg von
41,2 Prozent vor der Pandemie auf
46,5% danach und auch die Kritik der
monitoringstelle der
UN-Behindertenrechtskonvention zum
Gesundheitswesen ist eindeutig sie
stellt erhebliche Defizite fest Zitat
infolge der knappen Ressourcen in der
Pandemie haben die Barrieren und
Benachteiligungen für Menschen mit
Behinderungen noch zugenommen Zitat Ende
konkret heißt das das lediglich jede
vierte Arztpraxis auch für Menschen mit
Behinderungen zugänglich ist und das ist
völlig inakzeptabel
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
cdu/csu-fraktion bei all ihrem
Oppositionellen freundlichen Optimismus
diese Zahlen sind ihre Zahlen des
Scheiterns für die Politik ihrer
Regierungszeit seit 2005 und daran
ändern auch einige gute Vorschläge ihres
Antrages nichts
etwas erfreulicher ist allerdings dass
ihre damalige juniorpartnerin die SPD
nach langen Jahren des Nichts Tuns und
abstreitens das Problem zumindest
erkannt hat und diese Woche ein
Eckpunktepapier für mehr
Barrierefreiheit vorgestellt hat gut so
integraler Bestandteil dieses Konzept
ist ist ein noch zu gründen der Beirat
für die Bundesinitiative
Barrierefreiheit der bis 2025 ein Papier
vorlegen möge das ist unambitioniert
meine Damen und Herren denn das bedeutet
für die Betroffenen dass sie vor dem
Jahre 2030 sicherlich wenig an Umsetzung
und realer Verbesserung zu erwarten
haben und das ist schlecht das Konstrukt
eines solchen Beirates darf nicht zu
einer weiteren Verschleppung von mehr
Barrierefreiheit führen und als Linker
sage ich letzte Satz wir brauchen
unverzüglich mehr Barrierefreiheit also
liebe Ampelkoalition kommen Sie in die
Gänge und zeigen sie der Union dass sie
es besser können die Menschen mit
Behinderungen würden es Ihnen danken und
ich danke Ihnen
die Redebeitrag von Jens birkwardt von
der Linksfraktion in der Tat dieses
Thema angesichts all der Krisen auf der
Welt eines was ich immer etwas mehr
Gehör verschaffen muss jetzt hier ins
Weg der teilhabepolitische Sprecher der
FDP Bundestagsfraktion amput Herr
Präsidentin und Kollegen ich habe es
beim letzten Mal gemacht ich mache es
nicht schon wieder aber ich finde es
wirklich bemerkenswert dass in ihrem
wiederum genau 20 Punkte umfassenden
Papier
12 wieder aus dem Koalitionsvertrag und
dem aktuellen Eckpunktepapier kommen und
ganz vieles andere richtet sich an die
Länder aber wir sind im Advent
und deswegen will ich den Schwerpunkt
nicht so sehr wie der Kollege birkwald
darauf legen was in der Vergangenheit
alles nicht funktioniert hat sondern
nicht mit ihnen darauf legen dass es
tatsächlich nur mit einer breiten
Mehrheit in diesem Hause und in den
Ländern möglich sein wird die von ihnen
ihr adressierten offenen Baustellen
wirklich anzugehen und das will ich dann
im Einzelnen doch mal machen
ihr beziffer 1 verbesserte Programme für
mehr Barrierefreiheit über KfW und
andere hatte einen Haushalt tierischen
Höhepunkt im Jahr 2013 unter
Schwarz-Gelb danach allerdings sind die
Mittel weniger geworden jetzt wachsen
sie deutlich wieder auf also den
gemeinsamen Appell haben wir in den
Haushaltsberatungen umgesetzt
sie fordern dann die Verpflichtung
privater mit einer Übergangsfrist von
fünf Jahren das freut mich sehr denn die
Koalitionsfraktionen die damals in der
Opposition waren hatten ihnen sie
erinnern sich bei der Umsetzung der
EU-Richtlinie unserem Barrierefreiheit
stärkungsgesetz vorgeworfen dass die
2025 zum Teil aber in der Masse
eigentlich 2040 reingeschrieben haben
berühmten Bankautomaten und das nochmal
zu sagen müssen in Deutschland nachdem
was in der letzten Wahlperiode vor
wenigen Jahren beschlossen haben erst
2014 barrierefrei sein und dann übrigens
nicht mal barrierefrei aufgestellt also
sie können dann 2014 karrierefrei hinter
einer Treppe stehen das werden wir
ändern das haben wir im
Koalitionsvertrag auch schon adressiert
freue mich aber dass wir das jetzt
gemeinsam machen
sie fordern dann den öffentlichen Raum
des Bundes noch mal zu untersuchen um
eine Liste aufzustellen und die dann
abzuarbeiten da sind wir ein Stück
weiter sowohl im Koalitionsvertrag als
auch im Eckpunktepapier der
Bundesregierung wir wollen bauen und
Barrierefreiheit herstellen steht sehr
klar drin und auch da freuen wir uns
über Ihre Unterstützung wenn es um die
Haushalt tierischen Mittel geht sie
reden dann das hat mich besonders
überrascht von
Personenbeförderungsgesetz und den
Abweichungen vom Standard der
Barrierefreiheit in der Mobilität das
hätten sie eigentlich noch besser wissen
müssen als ich den 2011 hat Schwarz-Gelb
das Personenbeförderungsgesetz im § 8
Absatz 3 geändert und gesagt zum ersten
ersten 2022
erreichen wir im Regel
die Barrierefreiheit
ja nun reden sie allerdings von einer
Frist die haben zugehört die ist
abgelaufen und deswegen haben wir im
Koalitionsvertrag sehr deutlich gesagt
wir wollen jetzt nicht noch weitere
Ausnahmetatbestände machen sondern wir
wollen alle Ausnahmetatbestände bis
2026 beenden dafür wollen wir die
gesetzlichen Voraussetzungen dieser
Wahlperiode schaffen und ich bin sehr
beruhigt dass ein führender Vertreter
der Union
uns dabei hilft die Länder davon zu
überzeugen dass das der einzig richtige
Weg ist machen wir das herrlass zusammen
sie fordern dann an verschiedenen
Punkten zu Recht dass auch im
Fernverkehr und auch im Regionalverkehr
übrigens der Deutschen Bahn wir auf
Barrierefreiheit setzen auch da erinnern
Sie sich daran dass wir hier eine
Auseinandersetzung in den Jahren 2020
und 21 darüber hatten dass unter ihren
Verkehrsministern die Deutsche Bahn
Bestellungen ausgelöst hat für Fahrzeuge
die vermutlich nicht mal in dieser Wahl
geliefert werden dann 20 30 40 Jahre auf
den Schienen sind wovon Barrierefreiheit
überhaupt nicht die Rede sein kann im
Regionalverkehr ist es bei mir im
Wahlkreis und in ganz Niedersachsen aber
auch im Rest der Republik so dass die
privaten Bahn ist schon schaffen im
Regionalverkehr Verkehrsmittel
einzusetzen in die ich eigenständig auch
in einem Rollstuhl beispielsweise
einsteigen kann und dann erreiche ich
noch Sitzplätze die Regionalzüge der
Bahn die bei mir laufen erlauben mir den
Einstieg auch noch dann stehe ich aber
nur vor zwei Steinen Treppen einmal nach
oben und nach verbunden solche Fahrzeuge
haben sie erneut bestellt wir haben sehr
klar adressiert dass wir nicht nur
gesetzgeberisch sondern auch als
Eigentümer der Bahn diese Praxis beenden
werden ich freue mich sehr dass der
niederflor ICE der spanischen Talgo
alles was sie hier aufschreiben bereits
erfüllt umso unerfreulicher ist es dass
er nicht ausgeliefert wird weil die
Produktions- und lieferkettenprobleme an
der Stelle Schwierigkeiten machen er
wird kommen ich bin sehr fest davon
überzeugt dass wir diese technischen
Geräte auch deutlich stärker bestellen
werden und dann haben wir auch hier
einen gemeinsamen Punkt ein letzter Satz
zu den assistenzunehmen sie haben darauf
hingewiesen dass es jetzt tatsächlich so
ist dass sie im letzten Jahr den Zutritt
geregelt haben tatsächlich funktioniert
eher nicht ganz herzlichen Dank an das
bmas-hundeverordnung noch in diesem Jahr
veröffentlichen werden einheitliche
Kennzeichnungspflicht und dann können
wir das was sie auch schon
gesetzgeberisch wollten endlich umsetzen
dass wir außerdem Haushaltsmittel haben
um 100 Menschen tierpaare zu fördern ist
ein weiterer sehr guter Punkt also Wind
auf einem gemeinsamen guten Weg
adventliche Stimmung lassen Sie es uns
zusammen machen frau Präsidentin
herzlichen Dank
für die SPD-Fraktion hat nun die
Kollegin Angelika Gürtner das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja morgen ist
der dritte Dezember der internationale
Tag der Menschen mit Behinderungen und
es ist ein Aktionstag an dem alljährlich
in der Öffentlichkeit versucht wird das
Bewusstsein zu erneuern und zu schärfen
dass Menschen mit Behinderungen sich
noch immer im Alltag zu vielen Barrieren
gegenüber singen sei es die Treppe im
Eigenheim der viel zu klein geschriebene
Beipackzettel die fehlende
Gebärdensprache oder auch ein hoher
Bordstein im öffentlichen Raum trotz
vieler Fortschritte es gibt noch viele
Barrieren zu beseitigen und das ist und
bleibt eine wichtige Aufgabe
cdu/csu hat beantragt mehr Tempo zu
machen beim Ausbau der Barrierefreiheit
und ehrlich gesagt diese Überschrift
hört sich sehr ambitioniert an doch wenn
man den Antrag liest dann merkt man
schnell sie stehen noch immer auf der
Bremse ich will das auch mal aufzeigen
an einem Punkt den sie gemacht haben sie
fordern schnellere Änderungen beim
Personen beförderungsgesetz mehr
Barrierefreiheit im ÖPNV abgesehen davon
dass wir das Tempo ja das Thema bereits
auf dem Schirm haben dieses Gesetz haben
wir zuletzt geändert in der gemeinsamen
Koalition im Jahr 2021 und ganz ehrlich
ich muss sie schon mal fragen warum
haben sie damals diese Änderung nicht
schon eingepflegt wenn es Ihnen jetzt
nicht schnell genug geht erst auf der
Bremse stehen jetzt stellen wir machen
das passt nicht zusammen das wird
einfach unglaublich
weiterhin fordern Sie mehr Personal beim
Service an den Fernbahnhöfen ich will
sagen für meine Fraktion die SPD es ist
ganz klar wir wollen das Menschen mit
Behinderung selbstbestimmt reisen können
überhaupt kein Thema aber ihr Antrag ihr
Punkt ist nicht durchdacht vor allen
Dingen nicht bis zum Ende sie wissen
schon dass die Bahn auch ein
Fachkräfteproblem hat und was sind denn
eigentlich ihre Lösungen die sie dabei
anbieten wir arbeiten an Lösungen und
die legen konkrete Beschlüsse auf den
Tisch heute morgen Chancen
Aufenthaltsgesetz bürgergeldgesetz wir
setzen das Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz aufs Gleis wir tun
alles für zusätzliche Fachkräfte und sie
sie blockieren
die wichtigsten Punkte möchte ich auch
noch mal sagen ja aber mit vielen
Umwegen Herr Oellers das müssen Sie
schon auch mal sagen ich will auch noch
mal darauf hinweisen demnächst werden
wir in diesem Haus auch ein
Gesetzesentwurf beraten der eine erhöhte
Ausgleichsabgabe vorsieht und es ist
auch unbedingt und dringend notwendig
dennoch immer gibt es sehr viele
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer die
trotz Beschäftigungspflicht niemand in
ihrem Haus der eine Behinderung hat
beschäftigen wollen das ist doch ein
Punkt und sie kommen in ihrem Antrag
wiederholt überhaupt nicht auf diesen
Punkt zu sprechen aber ohne eine
Ausgleichsabgabe werden wir diese
Barrieren hin zum allgemeinen
Arbeitsmarkt für Menschen mit
Behinderung nicht überwinden können und
deswegen bin ich froh dass wir das jetzt
aufs Gleis setzen die Bundesregierung
hat auch die Bundesinitiative
barrierefreiheitsgesetz ein
Eckpunktepapier erlassen in allen
Bereichen es wurde mehrfach erwähnt
werden wir
das Thema Barrierefreiheit anpacken
gemeinsam mit Ländern und Kommunen und
selbstverständlich auch unter Mitwirkung
der Menschen mit Behinderung was in
ihrem Antrag überhaupt nicht erwähnt
wird ich fasse zusammen nach gut einem
Jahr Regierungszeit haben wir ein gutes
Paket vorgelegt um Barrierefreiheit
abzuschaffen es ist ein umfassendes
Paket ihr unionsantrag ist meines
Erachtens nicht zum Ende gedacht er ist
nicht konkret genug er wird nicht wirken
und der heutigen Stand ist aus meiner
Sicht nicht
zustimmungsfähig ich freue mich aber
dennoch auf die weiteren Beratungen
herzlichen Dank und schönes Wochenende
ganz so weit sind wir noch nicht
nach dem Wunsch von Angelika Glöckner
den in dieses Wochenende werden wir erst
durchaus viel später eintreten nach
weiteren gefühlt etwa vier
Tagesordnungspunkten Stefan Nacke jetzt
für die Unionsfraktion
Kollegen mehr Tempo fordern wir in
unserem heutigen Antrag mehr Tempo für
Barrierefreiheit und ein inklusiven
Sozialraum mehr Tempo das fordern aber
auch diejenigen die wir mit unserem
Antrag in den Blick nehmen beim Thema
Inklusion denken viele zuerst an
Menschen mit Behinderung dabei geht es
um viel mehr es geht auch um die Mutter
die mit ihren Kinderwagen nicht durch
den Kassenbereich eine Supermarktes
kommt es geht auch um den Großvater der
seinen Enkel in einer anderen Stadt
besuchen will aber den ICE verpasst weil
niemand da ist der ihm beim Einsteigen
hilft auch diesen beiden wünscht auch
diese beiden wünschen sich von der
Politik mehr Tempo für sie ginge es im
Alltag viel schneller wenn man auch an
ihre Bedürfnisse gedacht hätte
als sozial-ethiker habe ich in meinem
Studium gelernt dass man sich Politik
und insbesondere Ordnungspolitik
spieltheoretisch vorstellen kann zwei
Seiten müssen zusammenwirken Spielregeln
auf der einen Spielzüge auf der anderen
Seite grundsätzliche ethische
gesellschaftspolitische Ziele und
Vorstellungen müssen auf der Ebene der
Spielregeln etabliert werden so können
sie als Rahmenbedingungen für das
Handeln des Einzelnen Anreize entfalten
mit Blick auf unsere heutige Debatte
glaube ich dass dieses zweidimensionale
Modell zu kurz gedacht ist es fehlt eine
dritte Dimension und im Bild zu bleiben
wir müssen auch das Spiel Brett
mitdenken ich meine damit einen
Spielraum der nicht einfach da ist
sondern immer erst geschaffen und
gestaltet werden muss nur so können
Menschen zu Mitspielern werden also
Spielregeln Spielzüge und Spielraum erst
diese dritte Dimension bringt Ordnung in
die Politik demnach ist
inklusionspolitik nichts noch
hinzukommendes ein schönes Extra oder so
sondern nichts mehr oder weniger als
Ordnungspolitik
morgen ist internationaler Tag der
Menschen mit Behinderung deshalb haben
wir mit unserem Antrag der Ampel einen
Merkzettel aufgeschrieben für eine
smartere Gesellschaft die ein Programme
Regeln und Strukturen und urbane
Hardware vom Nutzer her gedacht werden
muss es geht um bauliches und Mobilität
und Digitalisierung um politische
Beteiligung um Katastrophenschutz und um
vieles mehr eine unserer Anregungen
möchte ich aber besonders herausgreifen
denn sie bringt großes Potenzial es geht
um das Thema Design für alle die sein
für alle ist ein Konzept für die Planung
und Gestaltung von Produkten und
Dienstleistungen und Infrastrukturen
damit sind Lösungen gemeint die
besonders gebrauchsfreundlich sind und
individuellen Anforderungen begegnen das
Ziel allen Menschen soll eine Nutzung
ohne individuelle Anpassung oder
besondere Assistenz möglich sein so wird
niemand stigmatisiert
ich wünsche mir dass möglichst viele von
dieser Idee angeregt werden es gibt
bisher nur zwei Orte in Deutschland an
denen dieser Ansatz in die Ausbildung
zukünftiger Gestalter integriert ist
einer davon liegt in meinem Wahlkreis
die Akademie für Gestaltung der
Handwerkskammer Münster dort werden nach
Auskunft ihres Leiters Manfred Heilemann
als Teil des gemeinnützigen
Kompetenznetzwerks in drei Jahrgängen 90
bis 120 Studierende erfahrungsbasiert zu
Multiplikatoren für das Design für alle
ausgebildet sowas muss in Deutschland
Schule machen
Design für alle realisiert die Idee
einer Ordnungspolitik die inklusiv ist
vor fast genau einem Jahr haben sie sich
das Bundesprogramm Barrierefreiheit in
ihren Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben
seitdem es nichts passiert das ist ein
unfaires Spiel es wird Zeit Liebe Ampel
etwas mehr für Barrierefreiheit und
einen inklusiven Sozialraum zu tun seien
sie keine Spielverderber machen sie
endlich Tempo
das Interessante an dieser Debatte ist
dass all die Missstände in Deutschland
seit längerem bekannt sind zum Beispiel
der Mikrozensus 2018 hat ergeben das zum
Beispiel nur 1,5% der Wohnung in
Deutschland überhaupt barrierefrei
gestaltet sind da sieht man wie lange
die Strecke und wie weit der Weg ist
weiter in der Debatte Präsidentin Liebe
DemokratInnen und Demokraten ich nehme
jetzt mal den letzten Redebeitrag als
versprechen und möchte mal in
ähnlicherweise grundsätzlich beginnen
wir haben morgen den internationalen Tag
der Menschen mit Behinderungen und ich
habe gestern wir hatten ja einen langen
Abend hier im Haus habe ich die
Gelegenheit genutzt noch mal historisch
zu recherchieren woher dieser Tag
eigentlich kommt und der fällt in
Deutschland in eine Zeit wo Gerichte
solche Urteile gefällt haben
auch die Anwesenheit einer Gruppe von
jedenfalls 25 geistig und körperlich
Schwerbehinderten stellt einen
Verminderung des Reisepreises
berechtigenden Mangel da das ist Leid
auf der Welt gibt es nicht zu ändern
aber es kann der Klägerin nicht mehr
wert werden das ist eine 64-jährige alte
Dame die in Griechenland Urlaub gemacht
hat damals im Jahr 1980 kann ihr nicht
verwehrt werden wenn sie es jedenfalls
während des Urlaubs nicht sehen möchte
dieses Leid
ist es nicht fürchterlich ja ist noch
gar nicht so lange her das Gerichte
solche Urteile geschrieben haben und ich
möchte Ihnen ehrlich sagen es ist heute
noch so dass im Prinzip viele Leute so
denken und deswegen müssen wir daran
arbeiten dass dieses Denken endlich
beendet wird an diesem 8 Mai
nachdem das Urteil gefällt worden ist
gab es die größte Demonstration
behinderter Mensch ich glaube sogar bis
heute in Frankfurt und ich glaube die
Frankfurter und wenige Menschen in
dieser Republik haben jemals so viele
behinderte Menschen auf den Straßen
gesehen und damals hat der Kampf um die
Menschenrechte behinderter Menschen
begangen und begonnen und dieser Kampf
den führen wir heute weiter weiter den
müssen wir heute als Parlament
weiterführen und wir sind heute auf
gesetzlich dazu verpflichtet weil wir
die unmen Menschenrechtskonvention
ratifiziert haben das ist ganz eindeutig
es geht um
Selbstbestimmung es geht um Inklusion
als Strukturprinzip es geht nicht um
einen Randthema für ein paar Menschen
sondern es geht darum dass wir unsere
Strukturen so gestalten dass zukünftig
alle Menschen daran teilhaben können und
wenn ich hier mal durch die Winkel
Blicke na da sitzen so viele die der
Babyboomer Generation angehören ich
können nicht vorstellen dass die Leute
die die nächsten sind die wahrscheinlich
irgendwann mal behindert sein werden die
angewiesen sind auf Pflege dass die in
dieser Lebensphase auf ihre
Selbstbestimmung verzichten möchten und
deswegen empfehle ich all diesen
Menschen die hier sitzen jetzt dafür zu
sorgen dass wir barrierefrei bauen damit
sie am Ende des Tages auch zu Hause
wohnen können dass wir ambulante Dienste
anbieten dass wir den Zugang zu
Leistungen
vereinfachen das sind die Themen über
die wir reden und das sind so gewaltige
Themen dass wir jetzt sozusagen unsere
Zeit nicht mehr darauf verschwenden
können über die letzten 16 Jahre zu
reden sondern wir müssen jetzt die Ärmel
hochkrempeln damit dieses Land auch in
dieser Hinsicht
zukunftsfähig wird und insofern Liebe
Union bin ich Ihnen dankbar für das
Angebot dass wir jetzt gemeinsam
streiten für eine inklusive Gesellschaft
barrierefrei ist und allen Menschen die
Teilhabe vollumfänglich ermöglicht
vielen Dank
so noch zwei weitere Rednerinnen in
dieser Debatte um Barrierefreiheit und
inklusiven Sozialraum auf Antrag der
Unionsfraktion wir haben jetzt Rascha
von der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen als
fortschrittskoalition wollen wir
Deutschland zu einem fortschrittsland
machen dazu gehört auch die
flächendeckende der flächendeckende
Ausbau der Barrierefreiheit denn
barrierefreiheit ist ein
Qualitätsstandard für ein modernes Land
wie wir es sein wollen aber
Barrierefreiheit und die Politik der
Union passt leider nicht ganz so richtig
zusammen in ihrem Antrag schmücken sie
sich damit das in 16 Jahren
unionsgeführter Regierung angeblich
Zitat bereits viele Wegmarken für mehr
Barrierefreiheit in unserem Land gesetzt
wurden so schnell scheint sie zu
vergessen dass sie es waren die in den
letzten Jahren bei jedem noch so kleinen
Schritt auf der Bremse standen wer sich
um das Thema Inklusion gekümmert hat das
war die SPD vier Beispiele Erweiterung
dass
Behindertengleichstellungsgesetzes das
war das Thema ist das Barrierefreiheit
stärkungsgesetz das war auch das Thema
ist Zutrittsrechte für heiter von
Assistenzhunden im Privatbereich hat das
geregelt und das Thema es hat die
Initiative Sozialraum inklusiv initiiert
sie schmücken sich jetzt in
dreisterweise für die lange Zeit der
großen Koalition mit fremden Federn
zieht jetzt ein lange von ihr
vernachlässigtes Thema hoch sie
schreiben im Koalitionsvertrag der Ampel
ab um uns gleichzeitig vorzuwerfen zu
wenig zu tun das schon ein bisschen
billig das müssen sie sich jetzt anhören
während sie also Lobhudelei für
gesetzliche Verbesserung der letzten
Jahre für sich beanspruchen für die sie
kaum sachlich etwas beigetragen haben
benennen wir es Ampel klar das ist noch
etliche Lücken gibt die jetzt mit
unserer Bundesinitiative
Barrierefreiheit angegangen werden und
es steht ja auch klar im Eckpunkte
passiert so sind nur rund 1,5% der
Wohnungen in Deutschland barrierefrei
oder Barriere Arm nur ca 26 % der Haus-
und Facharztpraxen barrierefrei weil
staatlichen Webseiten sehen wird dass
sie teils nicht barrierefrei sind und in
einer Umfrage der Aktion Mensch geben
ein Drittel der Befragten mit
Beeinträchtigung an nicht selbstständig
im öffentlichen Verkehr unintelligible
unterwegs sein zu können weil sie eben
die zahlreichen Barrieren nicht
selbstständig überwinden können und das
sind nur ein paar Beispiele an denen
sich zeigt dass diese Bundesregierung
eben nicht davor zurückschreckt Probleme
klar zu benennen und dann auch klar
anzugehen das machen wir jetzt mit
dieser Bundesinitiative und natürlich
Herr öhlers ärgert sie das dass jetzt in
einer SPD-geführten Regierung Dinge zum
Fliegen kommen die unter ihren
CDU-geführten Regierungen nie zum
Fliegen kam zu wenig zu spät CDU und
oben drauf kommt dass Ihr Antrag mit den
vorgestern beschlossenen Eckpunkten
erledigt ist während die Union nur
abschreibt und gleichzeitig von
Versäumnissen der Vergangenheit ablenken
will geht diese Koalition voran setz den
Koalitionsvertrag weiter fleißig um und
geht mit der Bundesinitiative weiter als
opportune Forderung ich freue mich auf
die beiden weiteren Beratung und danke
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
so das war schon die letzte Rednerin für
diesen debattenpunkt Barrierefreiheit
und inklusive Sozialraum und weil auch
gerade von der Rednerinnen und von
vielen anderen nochmal darauf
hingewiesen wurde dass es diese
Bundesinitiative Barrierefreiheit gibt
vom Kabinett diese Woche beschlossen
kann man an der Stelle noch mal ganz
klar festhalten 2025 bereits will die
Bundesregierung darüber berichten was da
rausgekommen ist das heißt noch mal zwei
Jahre ganz viel Geduld